second day of III press conferences and
we kick today off big with Microsoft
from their new console to all the games
we're here to catch you up so stick with
us for the next few minutes
we won't waste time and Microsoft didn't
either on getting to the meat of their
presentation project Scorpio or as we
now know it Xbox one x-man I was hoping
for an ATAR first up we got a look at
the box and it looks like well a black
xbox one but it's actually going to be
the smallest Xbox ever the $500 machine
is equipped with an 8 core CPU 6
teraflop GPU and 12 gigabytes of gddr5
vram
as we expected xbox 1x is going all-in
on 4k with HDR microsoft promises 8
million active pixels and that even
though is playing in traditional 1080p
we'll be able to notice the difference
through super sampling Microsoft
announced that all your Xbox one games
and accessories will work with Xbox one
X and it'll be out on November 7 but
what's a cool box without being able to
see what it can do the first of the
games Microsoft revealed running on Xbox
one X was flotsam o sport 7 not only was
it the worldwide reveal of the game but
also the worldwide reveal of the Porsche
2018 911 gt2 RS both in game and IRL
there will be more than 700 cars
available in the game and it will be
quote the most technically advanced and
comprehensive racing game when it
launches on October 3
Fortson Motorsports 7 will run in 4k at
60 frames per second on Xbox one X and
that is already really hard to say
microsoft also debuted the world
premiere of Metro Exodus the new title
from for a games the gameplay trailer
showed off ominous apocalyptic ruins
skeletons and big nasty beasties of
course we saw two different weapons a
rifle and a crossbow before the
protagonist met up with a companion
aboard a massive train the game is
launching in 2018 after all those leaks
we finally got our first official look
at the next Assassin's Creed Assassin's
Creed origins and yep we're headed to
Egypt the main character is by yak the
last of the Magi we saw swimming rafting
a giant Cobra and of course parkour the
game features literal Falcon vision to
tag enemies and set waypoints counter
heavy combat and camel riding
interestingly UB have said they have
added deeper RPG elements Assassin's
Creed origins will release October 27
yeah gave us a taste of Bioware's new IP
and
yesterday but today at Microsoft we got
much more anthem will feature a huge
lush open world for you and your friends
to explore game director John Warner
showed off a gameplay trailer with a
crowded market a giant mechanical beast
and an NPC in need of help the game lets
you equip unique javelin exosuits
which can be equipped with jetpacks
mortars homing rockets and Shane guns
everything you need to explore and
survive the hostile lands anthem also
features dynamic weather and we have an
expected release window in 2018 let me
take a deep breath because there's still
more Microsoft's revealed the player
unknowns battlegrounds is coming to Xbox
with Xbox 1x enhancements to follow
Microsoft also debuted fighting game at
Dragon bull fighters II or fighters they
only put it up on screen which as you
can imagine features Dragon Ball
characters in beautiful cel-shaded 3v3
matches its drought in early 2018 Xbox
will also get the console exclusive
launch of MMORPG black desert online
state of decay to made an appearance via
a gameplay trailer which showed a group
of survivors banding together before the
trailer closed on a player choice we got
a look at base customization looting and
the tough choices players will need to
make to survive the apocalypse don't
fret you won't have to make those tough
choices for a little while as state of
decay two launches spring 2018 of course
it wouldn't be a Microsoft presser
without Minecraft and the big news for
this one is that the game now features
cross play across all platforms that's
right every device on the planet that
has Minecraft will now be able to play
with every other device that has
Minecraft there's also a super-duper
graphics pack coming this fall that adds
reflections godrays and 4k support and
that's all free oh boy there's so much
more I know how long it is like 20
minutes on the stylish front we saw a
brief trailer for the last night a
cyberpunk game that mixes lush high
fidelity visuals and lighting with pixel
art characters it totally looks like
gemini room and i am on board hot on its
heels was a platformer with a paper
character who wields a magical guitar
called the artful escaped vampire action
game code vain got another look in that
showed off more gorgeous visuals and a
release
state of 2018 the game that shouldn't be
nearly as fun as it is res multiplayer
pirate adventure sea of thieves got a
brand new gameplay trailer that included
all sorts of shenanigans like exploring
a sunken ship and an overgrown island
finding treasure and fending off sharks
and skeletons the gameplay demo also
introduced trading and shooting yourself
out of a cannon because why not unless
cool news sea of thieves has been
delayed until early 2018 but Tacoma a
stylish sci-fi game from gone home
developer fulbright got a release date
of August 2nd swings and roundabouts
Microsoft showed off a gameplay trailer
for the bright and colorful platformer
super Lucky's tale which will arrive
exclusively on Xbox one on November 7
and the perpetually unreleased cuphead
finally got a release date of September
29 finally in things that make press
conferences better a trailer featuring
Terry Crews introduced crackdown 3 and
the bright neon gunshots were plentiful
we also got the news that the shooter
will arrive on November 7 how is there
still more shadow of war the sequel to
middle-earth shadow of Mordor then took
the spotlight the highlight definitely
being Bruce the Ozzy orc rhino same
thing really there will be 7 orc tribes
in the sequel as well as the greatly
expanded open-world you'll be able to
forge an army of followers and assault
nemesis fortresses unfortunately the
gameplay demo ended just before italians
assault but you'll be able to play
shadow of war for yourself on october 8
in things that excite me we got our
first proper look at an older and
presumably wiser max in like a strange
before the storm and the wait isn't too
bad either as the first episode of three
will arrive on august 31st and the
sequels didn't stop there get your
fields in check because ori and the will
of the wisps is on the way with gorgeous
music lovely visuals and touching
critters
no release date for that one yet though
Microsoft was only not done with the
surprises though as the gigantic chair
of the show so far was won by the news
that original Xbox games including
Crimson Skies will now be included in
Xbox one backwards-compatibility
so that's everything for Microsoft to
stick with us because we will be
covering every press conference or e3
and do you remember to
got the GameSpot now app which is free
on iOS and Android so you don't miss out
on any of the news we will see you again
later for Bethesda
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Calma Calma this time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's e3 2017 I am rob joint here with
John Luke John Luke we played
Battlefront 2 on PC and had a pretty
good time but we were think about the
last game and namely the fact that the
last game felt so messy random and
unorganized compared to like what our
experience was with this game today
right yeah and I think the big thing
with that game was there were no classes
you know they as a player there was no
sense of objective or role within your
team there's no reason to coordinate
with anyone else on your team in this
game they have clearly defined classes
you can play an officer you can put down
turrets you can assist your allies you
can be a specialist where you have a gun
that lets you shoot from a distance you
can see allies you can point them or see
enemies you can play them out to your
allies so you have just a reason to
actually communicate with your teammates
like tell them what to do and actually I
coordinate attacks which really just
adds to that sense of teamwork yeah and
you're looking at now a post the last
game which had just the partner system
you're looking at your entire
four-person group right and if you guys
are grouped together you're getting
battle points
it raises right your val points and
raises as long as you're grouped
together moving around and then yeah
you're of course you said like you're
switching around classes maybe have too
many support classes we'll why isn't
someone be an officer so that was really
notable and then I would say the weapons
was another complaint from the last game
here they felt so much more diverse with
you know your SMG high fire rate low
damage your support classes that had
these loking machine guns that you could
just post up in like a doorway and just
hose down
what I found actually really cool was
the fact that certain weapons had
different types of active reloads right
where you have namely like a rifle it
seemed to have you know the red area
where if you hit the red obviously
you're gonna cancel your reload you hit
the yellow you're gonna get that quick
reload but then the green you know could
be a damage boost or maybe a fire rate
increase Springs a lot of unique and
different traits to each of these
weapons I found that very awesome and
then for me one of my favorite surprises
with the starships was the fact that you
could finally roll left to right the
previous game you were very much locked
on like horizontal planes so when you're
getting into like a flip and a dive it
was so frustrating to get out of it here
you are consistently able to like level
your plane and figure out where you are
as far as like the horizon and I was
just so gratifying because I've always
wanted that battlefield 1 had that it
gives more meaning to being a pilot and
of course interacting comfortably with
ground targets that's great and the
other main thing was the fact that the
previous game didn't have a health regen
you know you would get a dogfight say
you win you have 5% health left the next
interaction you have you're done there
is no point of like flying around with
5% health here you're able to you know
with a new boost our fighter hit that
droid and get a you know a quick revive
with your health or you can just you
know hang around maybe on the outskirts
and help your health regen so that was
really great yeah and the ships
themselves feel like they have much more
of a defined role as well this time
around in the original game you weren't
really able to interact much with the
ground it was random when you got a ship
so it felt like you weren't contributing
much to the overall a team objective and
this you can but the battle point system
you can choose to be I'm going to be
someone who focuses on playing as a
starter fighter as flying around you can
shoot at the objective you can shoot
enemies you can help your teammates out
and so I feel like as a pilot you were
able to contribute to your overall team
totally
[Music]
Johnny you were also mentioning the like
we have rush feel and the operations
almost right yes game-mode being much
more like more of a narrative compared
to like ocean Sun Walker salt
you'd have like a commander who's
talking to you and just saying like okay
we need to hold our ground we need to
take out this tank and then like okay
they got through we need to push back
when you to hold here and just having
that extra layer of a tiny story just
like adds like weight to what you're
doing where in the previous game it was
like you're on Hoth Walker assault
you've seen the movie you know what this
is just having that little bit of story
you're like really helps
the NGT has arrived in position despite
of severe damage terminate escort
program and begin combat cycle phase two
begins shortly I also quite enjoyed the
objective itself like at the beginning
it is it reminded me a lot of
battlefields rush mode where it's like
being on one side is defending the other
side attacking and linear push so in the
first wave the droids have this giant
transport that they are trying to
deliver and as the clones you have to
like pick up these ion cannons and try
and like target and shoot it down and
wasn't able to get it shot down but I
believe if you do that it probably ends
a match early I assume yeah but um they
were able to like get all the way
through and they blow open the door to
the to the palace at that point you have
to then hold these different sections of
the palace and then if they take that
you then go all the way to be' throne
room each area felt like distinct in
what you're doing
absolutely it felt like a refined
version of the Death Star dlc from the
previous game mmm which was like these
favors yet you're going into actually
different matches that are disconnected
this one was all encompassing but like
yeah you're playing one solid match if
yeah more like a narrative progression
rope we can't reclaim the
so yeah ultimately bow front to is
looking pretty good
I am excited I was a little surprised um
yeah I'm excited to see more really we
just saw this one map on feed um but yes
stay tuned to a game spa for more about
front to coverage next yep we already
knew that Microsoft upcoming console was
gonna deliver six teraflops of GPU
performance but with the company's III
press conference out of the way we
actually learned a couple new things
about the system we're gonna walk you
through them right now
so Michael the one of the first things
that we learned about the system is
actually the name it's no longer called
the project Scorpio it's called the Xbox
one X yeah what do you think about the
title
it makes sense in terms of keeping it
within the family of Xbox console so we
have Xbox one s which is a standard
console and excellent
we also price which is 499 dollars
that's pretty expensive what do you
think about the price it kind of aligns
with my predictions and a lot of other
people's predictions just because of how
much power this thing is packing into
one console it makes sense that it's
$4.99 but I think the interesting part
is like how is that going to compete
with the ps4 Pro which is $100 cheaper
it may be even lower yeah it seems like
it's more it's more powerful though oh
yeah definitely it's way more powerful
yeah
and I think you know the internet right
now is saying that it's pretty expensive
if you want something cheaper there's
the xbox one s we also got its release
date which is November 7 yeah so it's
coming out this holiday season yeah they
promised to deliver it within the
holiday season and it seems that they
are going to be delivering on that
promise then and then finally we got a
look at what you know the console looks
like you know what did you think yes
this for me I thought this was one of
the more impressive parts was they said
this is the smallest Xbox console to
date so not only is it way more powerful
it it's also compacted into the smaller
chassis to be able to do that yes
impressive more than the Xbox 1s which
is you know proximately 40% smaller than
Xbox one so they've really shrunk a hair
at the sides just like a smaller black
version of the Xbox one s yeah and it
looks sleek if I fit it anywhere in your
home entertainment system so you know
that was one of the cooler parts with
the Microsoft conference you know while
Microsoft is pitching the console is a
4k capable system the company also said
that it's gonna be making improvements
to 1080p gaming as well you're gonna get
faster load times and ass traffic
filtering and super sampling do you mind
walking through you know users through
what those some some of those things are
oh yeah super sampling is if you're in a
1080p display it'll essentially be the
image will render in like a higher case
imagine 1080 and then be condensed so
the image quality is much more fine so
people do don't have 4k displays will
still reap some benefits you know we saw
the games running in 4k but the whole
press conference and I never really saw
any massive frame drops enough I don't
think everything was running at a steady
60 frames per second yeah but rendering
4k is a feat within itself it's very
good man yeah
and nothing looked framing me nothing
looked like choppy overall with all the
games a shop will show it off from like
triple-a titles and E titles like look
great overall I'm impressed
think this is what Microsoft needed to
do looks all good to me gotcha yeah it
seems like it's a console that you can
get if you have 1080p screen now and
then you can get some benefits that way
and then later if you wanted to you can
output to a 4k TV and like you continue
to get better benefits right right and
then the last thing is you know the
console you know by itself is fine but
what about the games you know what you
think about the games they showed me a
SAS ins Creed origins I think was cold
Metro was Exodus which I thought looked
amazing yep what'd you think about the
you know the lineup of games and how
they looked okay well in terms of the
lineup
I was super hyped up for to see Metro
Exodus and see it running and looked
really smooth too cuz Metro has a long
history of being one of the more
graphically demanding games with 2033
and last light yeah now this one it's
like it's it seems like it's going to be
in that same line of impressively
yeah yeah yeah she's gorgeous ring at 4k
it's yeah on account unbelievable yeah
on a constable rested in for at 4k look
really smooth and to see you know other
games like shadow of war Assassin's
Creed you know they look great too
they're also rendering 4k only thing was
some of the lighting maybe some of the
textures weren't on par with what we
would see if we cranked a PC version all
the way up to ultra which is fine I mean
I'm not gonna expect a console to run 4k
and like super fine textures all at the
same time but they ran smooth which is I
think is the most important part yeah
look it look playable if you like this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to us on YouTube thank you for watching
started off their press conference this
year in style with a real-life Bethesda
land that was vaultboy statues revenant
statues and a ferris wheel I missed it
all but what I didn't miss was the video
games usually just to be here to help me
out but she was hosting a live stream
and speaking of which make sure you're
subscribed so you see all of our news
coming out of e3 but for now let's dig
into it everything Bethesda spoke about
at their showcase will be coming out
this year and they started off with two
virtual reality games if you can handle
the motion sickness doom is bringing
massive guns to your virtual space
Marine gauntlets and plenty of baddies
to point them at with doom VFR gates of
Hell not your speed you'll be able to
walk the wasteland build settlements and
battle super mutants in Fallout for VR
when it launches this October it's worth
noting that the entire game will be
playable in VR speaking of fallout
there'll be a steady stream of new
content for both it and Skyrim via the
newly announced creation Club things
like new armor weapons and gameplay
enhancements made by Bethesda and
collaborating outside creators will all
be purchasable with coins when the
service arrives this summer on ps4 Xbox
one and PC if you're playing Elder
Scrolls legends then good news the card
game is getting dark Brotherhood story
content in game tournaments and a chaos
arena most excitingly a heroes of Skyrim
expansion will hit the game on the 29th
of June when it arrives on iOS and
Android
so soon let's keep that Skyrim train
a-rollin the long-awaited Nintendo
switch version of Skyrim was shown off
along with some very nintendo features
you'll be able to cosplay in links
breath of the wild tunic as well as
wield the Master Sword by tapping your
link amiibo there are also motion
controls for swords shields and bows
which looks pretty damn cool
unfortunately no concrete release date
has been announced for this one yet but
keep an eye on Nintendo's press
conference for that Dishonored 2 is
getting some DLC in the form of death of
the outsider it starts the quest giver
from the main game Meaghan Foster as she
teams up with doubt from the original
Dishonored 2 knife of dunwall DLC the
pair appear to be teaming up to kill the
outsider the source of the characters
powers Meaghan Foster looks to be every
bit as formidable as Emily in Corvo - as
she teleports through walls and skulks
around behind enemies the DLC is set for
release on September 15 Bethesda also
used their showcase to position quake
champions as a major eSport they
announced a sponsored competition for
August 26 during quakecon there will
have a 1 million dollar prize if you
want to get some practice in the beta
has been reopened indefinitely and you
can sign up on the website right now go
go go go go go go go go
Bethesda closed their 2017 showcase with
two new games the evil within too and
Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus the evil
within - will launch on October 13 this
year and is being developed by the devs
of the original tango gameworks it was
revealed via a cinematic trailer that
looks as psychologically freaky as you'd
expect from Resident Evil creator Shinji
Mikami the protagonist from the first
game is returning this time in the hopes
of rescuing his daughter closing out the
show was Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus
and it just might be my favorite reveal
after a fake TV show about a girl in a
giant robot dog BJ blaskowitz was
revealed to be still alive and Nazis
have taken over America there's rideable
robot dogs crazy dual wielding weapons
and a comrade who drops acid yep it's
more of the same crazy action machine
game started with the new order and you
won't have to wait long to play it as it
releases on October 27 this year BJ will
also make the jump to quake champions
where he'll have his own attributes and
voice lines so that's Bethesda for this
year make sure you tune in tomorrow for
Ubisoft and Sony and make sure you grab
the game spot now up so you can get the
top 10 news stories of the day delivered
straight to your phone we will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
doh it's good to see you old man you up
for one last job Billy
who's the mark the black eyed bastard
responsible for all the chaos
[Music]
here you go Peggy as everything your
mother ordered and a ration card and
here's a locker each Necker just for you
Wow gee thanks mr. Wilson
[Music]
I'm gonna get you out get it off leave
oh good girl
[Music]
bad girl
[Music]
the nutrition is a matter of state
security when the bar soldier who ever
lived
[Applause]
welcome back to round three now is Berk
it's really exciting on America's number
one game show okay
hands on your buzzers here we go the
honorable use exercise self-control all
the joy and pain fix your show
Oh second balcony
was the place with meat second seat go
Dutch treat you were sweet
the old and the weak are due
[Music]
William I prayed for him to wake up
gotten so fat that says we're having
twins
uh Frau Inga
she's been hunting for you she's been
moving heaven and earth and today she
found you you think you're hero William
Joseph glass
[Music]
foster's did this monsters
hello come on Peter let's go someplace
else
mom no nuts oh btw sure duck you one
strawberry milkshake please oh I hope
you don't have a fire back there to put
out if so I'll come back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait come and done
one strawberry milkshake coming right up
fireman I recognize your face very Aryan
face at this to you at a station one day
you're calm not Oh
vielen dank hmm now you show me your
identification papers please
we got about the fighting spirit back in
the American people
[Music]
shucks
[Music]
just who the [ __ ] you write boy stay
calm
let me first make it absolutely clear
that I am NOT a Nazi were you saying say
your Nazi I'll [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me say this again I ain't no goddamn
Nazi huh
now you bring superfish back in and you
put him down right now
I will shove this grenade so far up your
ass ha
I got precious little time for your
[ __ ] we've been trying to make
contact with your groom we're organizing
for a revolution in America we [ __ ]
pick up yesterday Oh
for the longest time I've been hearing
through the grapevine about this
resistance leader
Partin you know mom always said she
never trust a man can't handle his
whiskey so you sit right down
say terror billion drink up now listen
Tara Billy I respect your infection but
there's nothing gonna be done no more
the world has sank into the crapper and
all we can do now is drink this whiskey
watch the vortex suck it all down didn't
expect your belly to be quite so yellow
we stood up against the imperialist war
machine in the United States of America
and the greedy money men of Wall Street
he was gonna send the children of the
proletariat up to die foreign lands so
that they could be filling their coffers
it worked their sons bleeding on the
beaches I got kids on the way and I'll
be damned if I'm gonna raise them in a
world run by these not yet
you take freedom away from the American
people you're playing with fire and I
intend for some ghastly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage we are prepping for ubisoft
press conference about half an hour but
we here on the GameSpot staff figure we
get together and talk about our
predictions for the show I'm your host
Mike my Hardy here with Kelly plaguey
hello Dave Jewett hello m-matt a
Spinelli hi so I want to jump right into
it so we don't waste any time
kal you saw Assassin's Creed origins
yesterday today's ago uh it's all
blurring together yeah a couple days ago
and you got to play it but we also saw
it I you know they shut it off during
Microsoft's conference which was a bit
odd because like Yousaf hadn't gone yet
but of course that that still happens
but i do want to talk about static read
origins because this is the first one
after they took a year off right what
were your impressions overall so far
almost interesting they're definitely
shifting towards more of an action RPG
there's a skill tree the combat is very
Dark Souls esque so it feels a sort of
like a refresh or you know a reinvention
of Assassin's Creed in a lot of ways and
I think that makes a lot of sense with
the whole origins theme it's about like
the you know how the Brotherhood got
together and I think that one of the
strongest things about the demo I played
I played for about an hour was exploring
this take on ancient Egypt it's really
rich NPCs kind of have their own
day/night cycles they operate on their
own terms and like you could have a hit
out on somebody and only to find them
dead killed by a crocodile and look cool
see that your quest and that you know
the hit was taken care of for you in it
so it's just it's a it's a moving world
at least from what I saw and so I was
really really intrigued by that it seems
more alive so I'm excited for it does it
feel like they're almost going for more
than style kind of like I don't know
like Far Cry games had that right were
yeah yeah like hunting someone but then
a tiger would come out of nowhere and
kill them for you but then also hunt you
and then that you'd try to flame throw
it in the grass with I'll land on fire
and you'd be screwed yeah actually was a
lot like that I thought I mean you just
saw it there I fought a crocodile
underwater and it just randomly attacked
my boat and sunk it and there was some
cool stuff going on like that and I'm
not really a big Assassin's Creed person
so I like to have a reason and I'm
already I'm such a huge Egypt nerd I was
like one of those kids who loved ancient
Egypt yeah
and so I was already kind of on board
with this and after playing it it
reminded me a lot of horizon okay just
in how the quest structure works in the
skill tree so I'm excited cool um yeah
it's it is like I think it's worth
noting obviously like they took last
year off which was nice because I feel
like a lot of people felt like
Assassin's Creed was kind of there
getting burnt out on it the last one
being a syndicate which also released
alongside rogue was it the one that was
360/ps3 no that was unity in rogue unity
and rogue and then syndicate was London
the year after yeah 2015 and it was nice
that they took a year off because maybe
you know like they had some time to
revamp some of it but of course there
are we've saw the combat in that
Microsoft press conference demo and it
seems much more like free-flowing combat
and it's not just the attack and counter
and like people are making Dark Souls
comparison but I get it like it's it's
the attacker map to your shoulder
buttons apparently and then also like
there's you have to read the enemy's
attacks and like dodge it through
accordingly or parry it with your shield
it gave like a Dark Soul flavor although
it's not a Dark Souls game at all but
the combat itself felt like it yeah
there definitely seems to be more of a
sense of reacting as opposed to
constantly right which is basically what
syndicates combat system was just based
on a lot of button mash sure so yeah
there wasn't much weight to when you
swung weapons in the Lego s two
assassins grief I like someone
frohe was said last night it felt like
you were just swiping a tear that seemed
like a lot more weight to it this time
around and kind of like I don't know I I
prefer to play these games with stealthy
way but like now I'm looking at there's
the three skill trees like hunter
warrior and seer yeah
seer was that like series kind of yeah
it's the most nebulous of the the three
categories it's like sort of like a mage
em it's like smoke screens and fire
resistance and stuff like that cool but
they all interlock actually so it's
really interesting you can kind of
overlap and blend so if you like if you
like sneaky Archer and Skyrim kind of
thing you can do that if you want to go
full stealth you can do that cool and
the combat does have a lot more weight I
played a boss fight and it was a lot of
dodging and parrying and and reading
okay that's interesting so for people
watching from home that and like ah so
and played the game yet do you think
we'll see anything like brand new today
um yeah that's like the weird thing
about them showing it off at microcell
yeah this was like you've Aesop's big I
mean obviously it leaked so much and
this was the the big surprise of it it
would have been so I'm not exactly sure
I really hope they show a little bit
more maybe something story related um
the demo we saw was was there was one
story mission we got to do and it was
very limited so I'm hoping maybe they'll
show something with that because the
trailer we got yesterday was so combat
heavy right like even something about
the protagonist would be good yeah you
know like bare bones skeleton he's last
Magi yeah that's about it okay um cool I
do I'm excited for Sanskrit origins but
I do one move on because there's a bunch
of things we know will probably see well
definitely far cry 5 that came out the
cover was revealed month or two ago at
this point now it's been a while I think
and you know stirred up like some
questions about whether they're gonna
make good use of this material that
they're presenting you know Montana in
like you know radical Christian occupied
Hope County as it were and you know you
wonder how well they're gonna use the
story to his advantages but all the last
fire card we played was primal in the
Stone Age which you know felt like a
reskin three and four just I love primal
actually I liked it a lot but this seems
like they're kind of going for a very
different flavor in terms of the story
uh Dave what do you think they could
show today that you think they will just
show straight up gameplay I might have
been those they'll they'll do the far
cry thing of like hey here's an
objective that you can do in here's a
number of ways you can do it like
there's always that the stealthy
approach or you know throwing bombs onto
a truck and driving in approached yeah
I'm guessing they'll do something like
that but also like to see them explore
the open world we see that a lot of like
the driving stuff the hunting stuff yeah
from like small town to small town I'd
be really excited to see that
or maybe just expand on some of the the
characters because I think it's so far
from we've seen there some of the
strongest draws for me there's a lot of
really interesting characters in this
game so far like the M the preacher
remember his name exactly but that kind
of character archetype in this setting
and it's like super creepy like a
religious person forced to do bad thing
yeah right yeah yeah that's badass yeah
I would like to see him just get like
going on a rampage sure yeah and I
really like where it's set actually like
even outside of all the teams they're
going for I like that it's inset in like
a flyover state we call them you know
like which is pretty
like insulting to people who live there
but I'm excited to see how it shifts
from these this pastoral landscape to
these fields to seeing these cows
walking around to coming across this
baseball field that no one uses anymore
under the occupation we were drawing
comparisons to the new Wolfenstein
yesterday just like occupied America
obviously they're the home front games
or obvious
you know kind of parallels you could
draw between them but Matt do you think
like is there anything they'll show more
of the characters do you think they'll
focus pretty heavily on gameplay like
showing people that open-world farcry
structure if it's intact if it's new
this time around or what do you think
they'll do yeah I definitely feel like
they have to really shift more towards
gameplay this time around cuz I mean
obviously we've seen some previews of
what to expect out of the premise and a
bunch of stats - yeah exactly exactly so
I mean I definitely have a feeling
they're going to show off a lot of games
on how that works but also potentially
maybe they might I think I'm hoping at
least that they're going to show off
something about how it's structured now
because I mean those previous far crys
in a way they're very kind of inspired
by some of the Assassin's Creed the sort
of design you're going up when towers
looking it's looking at stuff in order
to unlock sort of activities to do um
so I'm curious to see how that if
they're gonna reveal any details about
how the game is structured right yeah
that's the interesting thing too because
I mean it's weird I kept keep thinking
like if there had been a number of Far
Cry game last year or if there had been
an assassin's creed would I be as
excited as I were for these two games
but I kind of am yeah once I saw the
trailer and the tone they were going for
with Far Cry 5 like I said it remains to
be seen like Kelly I know you talk a lot
about it what it remains to be seen
whether they're actually gonna make good
use of this story these themes but once
I saw the actual like action and kind of
overall vibes taking place I'm I'm a
little more excited for it and I again
I'm hoping I'm assuming I think it'll
just like fade from black on like the
first person someone has a gun and then
yeah they're like probably somebody
narration like about what they have to
do go like in the grab some vehicle or
do something and just show off the like
you guys had the flow of the combat and
I'm looking forward to that I feel like
it'd be a missed opportunity they didn't
show a lot of that right um but then of
course a game that was supposed to come
out last December but also before that I
got delayed a couple times South Park
yeah record but he'll crap your instead
of a gritty I love I love like screwing
up the cadence the name of purpose know
the fractured but
whole um see more of it uh Kelly wait
did you play that too
no did you no okay no no okay you say
you so played Assassin's Creed okay but
fractured but whole I'm looking forward
to see what they're doing with it
because I'm actually interested in the
gameplay of it it's like more of a
tactical combat yeah first game was like
kind of a bare-bones like RPG party base
for tactical on a grid yeah yeah
everything um I don't know I'm I also
like just don't know what the hell's
gonna happen in this game cuz you're
picking a class in the last game and I
don't want to get into what happens but
get pretty South Park ish yeah but I
like that the first one felt like one
long South Park season Kelly are you
like a South Park fan do you like I I
know more about South Park than I have
any business knowing I love self parked
um I yeah my big thing with this is with
stick of truth I really liked the the
setting like the basis in the episodes
right like the no wizard kind of stuff
um this is the Coonan friends seem so I
that's not really my favorite set of
episodes um so I'm curious to see if it
relies too much on existing South Park
stuff or if it's going to really have
its own humor I think stick of truth did
that really well so I'm hopeful oh um
well yeah it's also like parroting the
Avengers Civil War right yeah yeah here
I was like split down the middle of
schism yeah yeah I don't know what the
hell is happening
um I mean that's the best that's the
best part
uh yeah um yeah I'm assuming they'll
show simpler I'm actually looking
forward to this I'm just I feel I'd love
looking up like South Park YouTube clips
I feel I'm gonna get the same vibe from
this press conference yeah here we go I
wonder where they're like where they
would put it because you go from the
seriousness of Assassin's Creed to South
Park and then back to Far Cry 5 doesn't
seem totally correct yeah yeah that's a
good point in Montreuil she's gonna
storm the stage or something I would
love that
it looks interesting what they're doing
like it's like twelve classes or
something ridiculous as a bunch but like
you mentioned the delays I remember
reading that there was a lot of
speculation that it was delayed to
rewrite a lot
connected to that time period that you
guys are having yeah
sitting election and stuff that time
period not like what's happening what's
happened to know yeah I read that on a
forum and I was like man I thought I'll
be awesome saying a game just to get bad
jokes by a huge man maybe having over to
maybe have a new villain at the end of
the game yeah right I legitimately
forgot you were British for a second and
I was like what you're talking about
America okay you guys are own so gonna
know that would make the third Ubisoft
game or no sorry third game that's from
this conference
yeah or III that's tackling American
problems but in the South Park Way South
Park way and then there's like the robot
Nazi way and then there's the just
straight-up far cry way mm-hmm um yeah
you guys think we'll see gameplay of
this or do you think they'll just come
on with like a trailer of sorts I reckon
you'll see gameplay and go release date
like it's it's about time it's had
enough yeah lays people people are hype
for it people and there's like there's a
lot of room for like the toilet humor I
say we have a release date October oh
yeah oh sorry but well definitely show
gameplay but yeah I mean yeah I mean
yeah now that it's kind of like cemented
in yeah I just really hope Matt and Trey
are there I just they've gotta be surely
such a huge Matt and true fan girl I
wanna see him did they come on the stage
for um the first game they came out oh I
forgive it was last year the year before
but there wasn't III where they came out
and I got really excited all right now
is killing it all right yeah okay okay
uh cool so moving on from uh so on that
day that they you saw kind of revealed
that there's gonna be a new Assassin's
Creed a new Far Cry and then there's
also like oh the crew to is happening
the crew one's kind of disappointment
Matt did you play the crew one much it
did not and unfortunately the idea of it
sounded awesome right like open-world
America driving across it yeah um but it
didn't kind of it didn't really come to
pass I think we we gave it a 5 out of 10
or something I guess yeah yes cool ideas
but a lot of empty space and it didn't
really pan out like they'd hoped I don't
think but um the crew to maybe you know
they learned a lot from that game and
now maybe that they've had more time for
it to percolate yeah better yeah I mean
if you have a good idea but you didn't
get the execution right a sequel is the
right place to do that so hopefully they
figure it out with this one
I'm assuming we'll see a decent amount
of the crew - I'm just sure we're
already sits because we're going to
we're going to have the new leaf speed
which never really takes itself
seriously and then we have like the the
simulator games like Graham for 37 years
so I'd be curious to know if if crew
wants to sit in between those or isn't
going to try and do its own thing mm-hmm
but like there's it seems like suddenly
we've just got a suite of races so we
need to do something to really stand out
I think especially like you're saying
after the lukewarm warmness of the the
previous game yeah if they want to make
a sequel and making a series than did
the Kansas did so the best view would be
if they got a car on stage that was more
expensive than the poor guy on them like
you're really good or they or they
brought like a Saturn up on stage
already they could be up three three
rila yeah Oh that'd be great um so I
want to get into some DLC things that
were likely to see Matt you've been
playing a good deal of for honor since
it released
I haven't worried yeah anyway every
might be right February Valentine's Day
right yeah it's right ah what do you
think you think we'll see the season
we're in season 2 season 2 you right now
yeah I think they'll show off stuff for
three new fighters new places new modes
I mean part of me thinks that maybe they
may not might not but I would really
love to see more heroes especially just
kind of because was it the last time we
got a new heroes from the samurai and
the knight clasp but we never really got
to see what they were kind of intending
for like you know another hero in the
Viking class I'm like really interested
in what that's gonna look like yeah and
also just like maybe just like yeah like
if they could like maybe provide some
more details of what's coming up in the
Rison that we can all get excited about
because because yeah the last major
thing was sort of season 2 and and sort
of those details so yeah definitely yeah
so did season 2 do much to revamp it or
was it just like you know more more to
play with it was just more to play with
okay flame but that said I mean the
characters
the new heroes are definitely sort of
this focus and highlight of the game so
it was it was substantial in that form
to me you know be went really cool if
actually I don't think they would do
this because it's kind of got a good
bounce now if they enter just like a
fourth faction that would grow because
what samurai Vikings Knights right now
even think about the fourth one be Jedi
cool boy yep definitely Jedi here uh
yeah what I have no idea before your
class with it yeah maybe like easy I'm
Mongol tribes so style like nomads yeah
I don't know seemed pretty balanced with
three factions right now sure I mean
that would be yet no too much yeah it's
only been two seasons so why you know
yeah ventolin from I've seen the
playerbase is kind of trickled off a
little bit so I think they they need to
inject some adrenaline into it yeah I
really enjoyed for honor but then I
played it for like a month and then I
felt no caused anymore I think it's
fantastic game yeah but I it would be
nice to have reasons to come back to it
outside of just the joy of playing it
because they had a lot there but um came
out right before a slew of like eight
fantastic games this year that Resident
Evil kind of beat that like rush of
games but yeah and then I just didn't
never went back to it so maybe like they
would introduce stuff that does he think
that the community evolved so fast as
well you I took a week off the game and
then all of a sudden the meta was
completely different I find it really
inaccessible whoo and that was just like
why the hell are you using an assassin
what do you like that's like the Hans I
mean yeah I know is I well now that are
are there characters not at the time at
the time of playing there was like a
super unbalanced character I think it
was the the Viking that could like to
charge people off yeah that's one of the
samurai who is like really really awful
to play against and apparently they they
bad in it but yeah you think a new
faction would remedy that or make it
harder for you to get back in like a new
faction would mean like way more
balancing yeah but I think it'd be good
starve if they're doing it right and
they can if they do a similar way they
did Rainbow six siege and Aria like slow
drip feed it right speaking of Rainbow
six siege just expecting the DLC for
that as well yeah don't off what's
called The Vow there's like a weird name
to it Auto combine it something what's
that
violet something with all of it velvet
something yeah yeah and there will be
you know like well this is actually a
good game to like to look at when you're
talking about for honor because the I
think the player base doubled since
released like a year after that's like
whatever really well and like
introducing new the new hero class what
everyone call new operators but
you have that like they came out and
everybody kind of reinvigorate the game
every time and people are really
dedicated this game it's a really good
game I like it a lot
and I would like to see you know this
DLC is not major but it's something that
they'll probably show because the
community around siege has been so
active I don't know Dave when's the last
time you play it have you been playing I
played it a bunch at launch and I
haven't really got back into it just
because it's one of those things if
you've got a squad of pals that you play
it with yeah and they don't really play
anymore that kind of lost it for me but
I can see myself getting back into
ceejai I've got such an appreciation for
like a solid tactical based shooter and
it's kind of refreshing to do that after
like like I play tons of overwatch which
is very good you know quit shooing
playing shooter that I really have to
think about is always refreshing but I
think it's just like huge props to them
for supporting it the way they've done
like I know they did a big update that
was a change to the matchmaking quite
recently so I think they just like you
know they deserve like major props for
that just for keeping this game alive
and like exciting and they've supported
like eSports leads which have actually
blown up way more than I thought yeah so
it'd be excited to see more of that and
read like play it play again yeah so
velvet shells the DLC the release a few
months ago that's right we'll see what
happens tonight when we actually when
Ubisoft takes stage and then wild lands
DLC I didn't play well but I wish I did
but I'm assuming we will see something
from that I know like Aaron Sampson and
a few people in our office played a
decent amount of it and it was a good
game like open world kind of co-op
didn't it didn't grab me but yes they
yeah you still see um it came out up in
that moment where there was already a
lot going on yeah
we are timing yeah yeah right yeah I
mean it was it was kind of at a point
where I I wanted to get into and I
played the beta but I think my beta
impressions were a little lackadaisical
the point where I wasn't excited for the
full release but I heard these and
things about it and I like the idea of
like it's almost like a open-world or a
co-op far cry in the sense that you're
kind of tackling objectives how you want
and in this open world and on Columbia I
think stand in and then just taking on
the cartel it seems like something I
want to play if it wasn't
you know didn't release among this
little other games well that's the cool
thing about DLC those like if the timing
for both this and you know for honor
like you talked about earlier was weird
or not great for us like introducing DLC
is a good reason to revisit it yeah at a
time that's a little bit slowed down a
little bit as far as like I think we're
evolved kind of started catching up a
lot of the games yeah
I'm suing in terms of DLC they have like
that's like a trifecta of potential DLCs
I'm usually the pan would you say it's
usually the patent like the three oh
yeah
right um I thought you said usually in
Japan yeah I would be not gonna steal um
cool yeah and then of course uh Matt
you're Beyond Good and Evil fan right I
do play the first one yeah yeah do you
guys think we'll see you two finally or
no crossing my fingers for it
uh I mean I think they confirmed that it
wasn't gonna be shown yeah I show em so
I was like II they'll just like totally
underhandedly be like oh no it's right
here one thousand nine when that
cinematic I think is it the 2009 they
showed it with pig and yeah imma go
ahead thinking about it but yeah I mean
that game has been in development for so
long and it to hear that it like they
are going full in on it is great but
yeah I mean I I'd love to see more about
from that work it's like but the first
game was just this really
underappreciated gem that like really
deserved to be iterated upon again and
so like seeing more of like the sequel
would be would make my III some extent
what what a cool baton switch that would
be to be like no it's not gonna be here
and then surprise at the end of the
comfort layers of bluffing there is
another there was that a gameplay they
showed to where a character Jade yeah
yeah she was like parkouring that
village and now it looks dated but at
the time everybody's excited because you
knows it's a cult classic I guess idea I
played Beyond Good and Evil and I have
to say this and I'll confess I don't get
it wow I don't get why people like it so
much
the only connection I have to be on good
evil is that I I asked for it for
Christmas when it first came out and my
mum bought me the wrong game
and then I got never oh man she put
Marge Simpson on you it was it was
something they wasn't like you know Li
Carvalho is putting challenged
completely different game I was like
I'll never play it's them why is it just
like that is a half-life 3 thing where
people it's just like a like a urban
like a white whale
yeah I never get all right over like why
should I like the first game you know I
don't I mean at the time when it came
out I just had this very interesting
aesthetic to it I mean it was very sort
of dystopian but it had a more
cartoonish style as well and I guess I
had these elements they're kind of
similar I would say like I mean I guess
like kind of zelda-esque to some extent
and it just at the time was refreshing
in a way when you compared to a lot of
what like during that time a lot of big
games were just sort of these Triple A
platformers right now so right that's
why I really appeal to me right spoke to
me yeah yeah so time will tell if we
actually see it I don't think you'll see
it tonight or yeah today but uh I do
want to get into kind of predictions or
even just like dreams about what's gonna
happen uh I'll go first I want to it's
been how many years now three or four
four or five since we saw the last
Splinter Cell and you look at wild lands
is just released siege is really healthy
um see like actually Tom Clancy
properties are doing really well you had
the division come out as a new IP feels
like it would be the time for a new
Splinter Cell I'd be surprised if we
didn't see something with Tom Clancy
yeah I am attached to it and some inner
self is the one that's outside of DLC so
what it tells the one existing that I
can think of that today would show I
can't imagine what you like future
advanced warfare and like you say it
seems like the right time for another
bitter sell like yeah like now Gear
Solid has been in gangai antastic and
that really Reese parked the love these
stealth games to me so I would adore
another spend a set on the last one was
like terrific its co-op modes and stuff
like life worse yeah yeah it was amazing
I played tons of that so if they can
really build on that and use some of
what they've learned and maybe some of
the new stealth mechanics certainly new
stuff games like having yeah well so
that'll be a solid is like in a post
Metal Gear Solid world at least it's
cool to seed and I don't know
also really tackled the open world
stealth games yes I mean you have like
light stealth elements in Far Cry games
or wild lands but no you're solid with
five was a stealth game in an open world
and it'd be cool to see if like Splinter
Cell could take it there yeah at the
same time I wouldn't even note I
wouldn't even mind a really fine-tuned
linear Spanish doll either true true I
mean beef refreshing and it's in its own
way compare because you know mal we have
Metal Gear but like even then yeah just
like to see how Splinter Cell will be
able to soar because it was Oh they've
always but there back then there was
this sort of competition between those
two friends I'm Stan and so I'd love to
see a new minor so I've been a huge fan
that series for a long time and plus I
think it would be also great if they got
Michael Ironside back again was there a
mistake in thinking there was a tweet or
something does he tweet my clients oh
yeah enough a dating probably know but
like grass my voice is sworn like there
was some sort of like rumor recently
that he might want to reprise it maybe
I'm think I'm like David Hayter I think
I heard like today came thing and I feel
like it hurts out that Sam hey I've done
yet ah but yeah so you think you'd like
to see them because like blacklist kind
of go down like there's three different
mission types and then you have like the
carrier hub or the plane or ever get on
but you could also go down like these
assault missions and then you go down
the ones we can't be seen and then the
coop ones do you think you'd like to see
them tackle a branching structure like
that or something more like chaos theory
fine-tune stealth game well I think
caster is the best one I really like the
branch and structure because when I play
spin a Cell I always go non-lethal for
stealth but that branching structure
gave me an opportunity to be like okay I
can use some of the guns that the game
is this built boom I've only ever used
like the tranquilizer gun so that was
that was really refreshing because I got
a chance to play it kind of forced me to
play in a different way without
penalizing me mm-hmm
so again that could that could be fun
and like but it's really good open-world
I think really rejuvenate Splinter Cell
bring it to like the current gaming like
space yeah and then about the Rabbids
we've been hearing the rumor of this
game for a while now right that they
were coming back
I just Mario rabbit than cattle Kingdom
kingly I just want to say that my
wildest dream for this conference is
that that's not real okay go we were
kidding
sorry about that horrible image that was
on your Twitter feed for
hired a we're so sorry it's not
happening I
something about rabbits makes me mad I
justify of the minions that way yes
awesome yes yes if they're like minions
that horrible like picture of like
Rabbids peach taking a selfie like make
me want to die so I just don't like
these rabbits I don't like I'm not
speaking for them but uh people want a
rabbits game rabbits on switch you know
yeah I think it I don't know if I heard
this from the right thing but I kinda
think I heard that it has RPG like it's
more of an RPG yeah anything like a
Mario RPG look yeah we know
Maira tactic don't do Mario RPG but
rabbits and Mario like Mario was just
done and he got a plan how the he shoots
and stuff I don't know alright no to it
um anything else really missing there's
a couple I'm missing that
oh just dance just dance I'll have it
done that'll be a thing yeah yeah um
will they do it on stage
I'm I'd be so really surprised if they
didn't that's kind of their thing that
my thing my negative dream is that they
don't dance makes I'll have we all have
one that I don't have difference I've
never played Just Dance
I can't dance yeah but you're well made
games from whatever kind of that game
bank for them so I'd be surprised if
they didn't have like a weird dance
number and I'm not gonna get in unless I
get it rabbits DLC down the road yeah no
that's the dealmaker they'll mail you
right um yeah these are fun it's a good
workout like it's I I'd be shocked if
they didn't have something yeah outside
of those you know like we have
Assassin's Creed coming back with far
cry coming back we have you know all the
Tom Clancy games are doing well like I
would love a splinter cell I think
that's my wish um but is there anything
else seem too steep ah de si si si too
steep ah Alex new house on our staff
here is like a big steep fan I like a
real often steep fan I think he said he
had 90 hours and steep which is what
without the rest of the world he's gonna
rush the stage in like five seconds but
yeah I said one of the DLCs around
Christmas was uh you get to use it to
bogging that's a Calvin and I like
Calvin and Hobbes I guess but um do you
want Steve DLC I mean I haven't played
Steve I maybe I should try it maybe Alex
there's something to it I wish he was on
stage I'd make a switch
it's not on Swisher Connie's hand right
yes yeah I need you be soft gonna bring
anything in the switch maybe the rabbits
oh yes early oh well they would have to
but then maybe Nintendo's gonna announce
it yeah tomorrow I mean but last year
Ubisoft ran so much like it was like so
much longer than anyone expected so they
could completely surprise us and yeah
there's the potential for just brand new
IPs that we have no idea about like not
just existing franchises um so we have
yet to see what they're actually going
to announce but yeah sanskrit origins
far cry 5 South Park the fractured but
whole crew to for honor
hopefully a Splinter Cell but it sounds
like a lot of DLC
but then you know like returning sequels
we'll see a ton of the Sanskrit I think
we'll see something new with Assassin's
Creed outside of just like you know
obviously what they showed us I mean
it's good it's it's the baby right they
need to really give it some love yeah as
luck would have it Ubisoft starting
right now but if you're watching from
home stay tuned after because you can
watch the stream right here but we're
gonna do a post show as well and talk
about what we saw so we're gonna switch
over to that right now see you later
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
and thank you we've always wondered what
could happen if our crazy rabbits were
unleashed upon the world of mayo today
the dream is reality and to talk about
this unexpected encounter it is my great
honor to welcome a very special guest
someone I truly admire
Levin Miyamoto son
thank you for coming your so IP to have
you today so what what have you brought
oh you well what did you bring this is a
right side paprika a one of the weapon
from this game
Wow cool I'm sure you'll love it I
brought one for you okay oh thank you
[Applause]
listen we can't have a conversation
where a morale no ghostery go to the
Chiodo these are a little bit different
from the weapons you see in Ghost Recon
how are you
yeah very different weapons very
different Wells this one is I think very
effective in the world of my own rabbit
so should do well
and I'm so proud of you be soft
long-standing collaboration with
Nintendo you know from the ds2 the Wii
and more recently for the impressive
launch of the switch you know it has
always been we have always been inspired
by Nintendo and by all the great work
you have been able to do so it's now
home buddy
I know it's not UVA Sonya Nicole
acquitted a target over Dennis yes thank
you very much for all the work that
we've been able to do together over the
years with Ubisoft more ah they are
together did you go nowhere that doesn't
listen I mean Yves it's already been
about 25 years since you and I first met
there is little any crouton Vinny you
guys are no booze no Pokemon stare the
video dr. Murad a no Channel video and
it was your study semester and every
year at e3 you're kind enough to invite
me to your booth and we get to take lots
of pictures and videos and I've even
recorded messages for Ubisoft employees
in the past assault on Madinah Nabi I
know Kai has no - on dosukoi a Nintendo
game y matado no can can you take much
so over the years I've always felt a
deep heartfelt passion that Ubisoft
developers have for Nintendo and it's
characters disorder Bowden a Bhagwan
Onizuka has selfish their dive of this
gonna go see their Combaticons
but on the other hand because we're both
software developers we've also looked at
each other's as kind of rivals and and
tried to see who could make the best
software no ma I know it was Langer
Davidson on you know monetary orders de
boku no second no money motive it's like
pardon des kodomo no so you dive it's no
humor super boutique isomers
but of course I've known the rabbit's
characters for many years and I have
many rabbits figures decorating my desk
Wow so I've always been a fan of the
characters and their humor dark own
kinda hanashi wa ato de la vista Cadorna
emo gave monetary mr. Kazu astonish me
nice thoughts so since this project
first started I've been very excited to
see what kind of humor the rabbits could
bring to the mario world they thought
that I know that was a sunny otaku be
then that is a nice toast I got a
license so when I met David Ison who is
the
a creative director of this game
when I when I met Davide son I had just
just one condition for this project the
cycle genesis of the game poker so you
put up the home games are not there
mario de mama discovered on an agenda
nor gave matsutake Tony isomers I said
whatever you do don't try to make a jump
game or a Mario platformer try to make a
Mario game that has never been made
before look at that and it's great and I
can tell you it was an exciting very
exciting challenge for all our teams and
I think we've done something you will
owe so thank you very much for giving us
a chance to to perform on this game
hi Antonio no for Europa discrete
okinawan Amida give no katakana segura
IDO you be a sci-fi action game ooh
Santos good education and a concerted
Tansen of strategy game Tijuana no tanto
Co tempo no II gave medical advice and
so of course because the game is being
made in Europe it has a very unique
flavor to it and of course Ubisoft is
very good at making action games but
this game in particular has a great
layer of strategy and tactics to it but
with a very good pace ya know it's going
to be fresh actually and so no let's
welcome
zabi a you know the the producer of the
game and he will show us the game
[Applause]
finally finally we can talk about this
project so we've been working on this
game for more than three years now and
to be at e3 today on this stage it's
just super exciting
so what is this game exactly
so Mario plus rabbit's kingdom battle is
a tactical adventure exclusive for the
Nintendo switch and let's check right
away some gameplay
[Applause]
[Music]
so the rabbits have been teleported into
the the Mushroom Kingdom
and it made the world completely
unstable and chaotic so Mario as a true
hero wants to save the day but this time
with some new friends
[Music]
and at first they don't really know each
others but in the end double form this
dream team that will potentially save
the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and as the game is a turn-based tactical
adventure game combat is a really big
part of the concept so you'll fight wave
after wave and rabbit that somehow
turned bad and what we see here is just
the very beginning of the game so it'll
be perfect to talk about the combat
basics so the two flags you see on the
screen here is to tell you this is a
battlefield zone so you'll switch from
exploration mode to battle mode the blue
zone is your zone of movement so you
move anywhere you want in that zone but
you can also use battle filling readings
such as covers for protection so rabbit
Luigi here using half cover or full
cover and we also have what we call team
jump so by jumping or your teammates you
can expand your zone of movement so here
rabbit peach using Mario she's able to
flank the enemy so you can also attack
the enemy behind that cover and expose
them by destroying that cover which is
really interesting in terms of strategy
because for next turns you'll be open
for attacks and that's but not least
techniques
so from defensive ones like rabbit peach
shield boost or offensive ones like
Mario's hero site he's able to attack
the enemy even if it's not its turn as
soon as the Emme moves
so this is a very core aspect of the
game itself so you mix and match attack
options movement abilities techniques
but we also have other ingredients such
as pipes rabbit pipes so it does give
you a a good move to flank the enemy so
here for example rabbit Luigi goes into
the pipe out of the pipe - the enemy
goes from Mario team jump land behind
the enemy in one single movement
sequence and then finish off the enemies
and what we see here is actually a
explosive cover so those have many type
of a super effects and this one was a
push effect so you can push heroes or
enemies out of the boundaries so again
this is just a glimpse into the basics
of the game and as you progress into the
game you have more tactic tools you'll
be able to do more combo setups you'll
be able to use different type of heroes
different type of weapons in order to
battle your way through the kingdom
you
[Music]
thank you and that's and that's just a
glimpse into the game itself but first
and foremost this is a project done with
passion with our hearts so it would not
exist otherwise so we just can't wait
for you guys to try the game at e3 this
week for those are not at e3 you'll see
online coverage videos and surprises so
have a great conference have a great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi a match off his mill game director
for Assassin's Creed origins I've waited
a long time to say that almost 10 years
ago I as many of you fell in love with a
game that game took us to the Third
Crusade and we fell in love again wanted
to custody Italian Renaissance over the
years this amazing series has taken us
to the American Revolution the French
Revolution Victorian London and of
course to the Republic of pirates for
the 10-year anniversary of Assassin's
Creed for our fans for ourselves
and for all newcomers we wanted to go
back very far back to show how it all
began since Black Flag over the last
three and a half years we have poured
our energy our talent our passion into
bringing the land of pyramids pharaohs
and mummies to life to bring ancient
Egypt to life now Egypt challenged us it
fundamentally challenged us to reinvent
what it means to be Assassin's Creed and
over the next few days you will see play
and feel this reinvented experience I am
deeply honored and proud to be here
representing the amazing work of a
phenomenal team and thrilled to finally
be able to show you this beast we have
been building without further ado here
is a taste of Egypt
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
Lasha cream
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
as an extra treat let's check in with
home base where we're going to get a
glimpse of what you'll see right after
the UB conference hey there folks Chris
waters here at the home base with Hanny
Duong and Carl Lewis / do sir
on Assassin's Creed origins at Ubisoft
Singapore Carl's here to give us a look
at the gameplay of the game we're going
to be entering the open-world we've got
a ton more to show you but Carl kick it
off give us a little taste here open
world of of Egypt this is the demo that
we will be showing on the show floor
here at e3 byuk is riding into the film
one of the the regions in Egypt that's
most southernmost region it's a
beautiful area we see we've come in from
the desert moving towards this Lake
Morris and let's have a little
exploration around here using our Eagle
see it's sunny on the lake and it's
sunny on the monitor here but folks this
looks really good it's running on a xbox
one X it'll be giving you the gameplay
feed after the show we've got 30 minutes
of that coming up but let's see if we
can see you from a bird's-eye view
what's a new is up to yeah so say no is
looking into this military camp and
tagging a few enemies here after after
the show we will infiltrate this camp
and take it out either through stealth
or combat or perhaps range weaponry
alright if you guys want to see more of
this be sure to tune in right after the
conference Chris and I and Karl here
we'll be right here at will be joining
us as well you won't want to miss it
that 30-minute slab gameplay feed is
coming up after the show but for now
it's back to the stage and on with the
excitement that's it for now thank you
so don't forget that you can watch this
demo in its entirety after the
conference livestream from our home base
and for those of you here at a3 please
come to the Ubisoft booth where you can
live this new experience of Assassin's
Creed thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
hey PC chance
[Applause]
in our new hotshot driver with a
promising career dominate off-road
racing on his way to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there's a scheme Chloe there's a
wreck the charger growing up our
champions around it
[Music]
a sports champion coming out of nowhere
to rise to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you two years
back the crew to the driving genre out
there to be wide open world of the USA
thanks to our players we have taken with
iconic vision to the next level they
showed us what the light and what they
wanted to see in the futures now it's
time to take it way beyond driving i am
stefan beret creative director this is
the crew - yeah
Tyger Tyger
here in the US motor sports are louder
bigger AG than anywhere else in the
world drivers and fans meet across the
country and celebrate a common passion
for all things motorized now's your
chance to join in ladies and gentlemen
welcome to virtru - all of modern nation
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the heart of the city street racers
prove their skills skidding on rooftops
burning asphalt and tuning their rides
you
[Music]
[Music]
forge your own path off road through the
striking beauty of nature
tame and predictable waves on the open
ocean rapid waters or narrow rivers
fearless pirates rules guys spin between
buildings through the clouds among
stunning stunning perspectives
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all across the country i arctan contest
a will to take the lead on modern nation
you've had a glimpse of the crew to
register now for beta access or flavor
GMO adver booth experience TC 2 for
yourself enjoy the ride thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
we all started as one team we all wanted
to be superheroes for the same reason
you're a traitor tweek and now you're
with a group of super traitors this was
started by you we are the ones who walk
down the [ __ ] franchise mysterion why
would the free to pass out luck we send
a spy someone in our group who pretends
to want to switch sides and join freedom
packs
somebody who they don't know very well
well that's fair in love and war freedom
busy [ __ ] animal you got problems new
kid whatever you did last night got a
lot of people's attention
bad people if you need information just
know you can rely on call girl who does
[ __ ] is that so I guess now any [ __ ]
[ __ ] thinks they can be a superhero
we're gonna rip you apart do mysterious
visit you kids
[Music]
hello toolshed toolshed is a catchy to
your class visionary architect and a
[ __ ] trader
[Music]
Eric you must listen to me get out of my
head Timmy your franchise is going
nowhere
face the truth Eric you guys are kind of
douchebags
he just caught his douchebags in my mind
he did stop the fractured but home
available October 17th
[Applause]
[Music]
there was a sort of synergy of we're
looking to do something interesting in
VR and we've got this division and
you're looking to sort of bring you know
what sense you have of storytelling
within and put that into the context
that we are you can for the first time
as a player feel like you are in a movie
that's a really good word for it we want
you to take off the gear and still feel
unsettled
[Music]
what's working with Ubisoft we stumbled
across some fascinating research that
had begun in the late 90s essentially
neuro scientists had figured out a way
to upload brain data trauma emotional
emotions memories to the digital space
now we've gone and taken the next
logical step and really some really
creative in virtual reality
one such pet up in five we'd like money
to come in join us and experience the
walther test case for yourself that how
do we don't ever again
[Music]
[Music]
what you were experiencing is a recorded
consciousness it's not like watching a
movie so no matter how real it may seem
it can't hurt you
you were completely safe you're
completely safe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now I'm happy to share a new
surprise with you
building on the legacy of one of our
most popular world's two super talented
teams of you beasts of Singapore came up
with something really really unique so I
want you to see that and enjoy thank you
[Applause]
men from all over the world sail the
treacherous trade routes of the Indian
Ocean the riches in their holes fuel
their dreams of power and fortune while
wetting the appetites of those they fear
most pirates
when decides after 70 years
the way he goes therefore is to unlock
the door
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
120 days that's how long the average
pirate survived a lawless life on the
seas during the Golden Age of piracy I'm
Justin faring the creative director for
skull and bones and this is your chance
to not just survive but to climb the
food chain and surpass a legend of every
pirate who ever sailed the high seas
since bring an innovative naval combat
to Assassin's Creed we at Ubisoft
Singapore have set out to bring you the
ultimate pirate experience a tactical
action game where we take that naval
combat to the next level mastering the
ocean and its wins at the helm armed to
the teeth and together terrorize the
trade routes of the Indian Ocean season
after season you'll collaborate and
compete with other bloodthirsty players
even execute ruthless betrayals in order
to become the ultimate pirate kingpin
now I'm proud to share with you the loot
hunt one of skull and bones 5 vs. 5 team
based PvP modes right on right
we've just received Intel that merchant
convoys rich with treasure are sailing
just off the coast of Madagascar but
beware
there are other pirates
the Priscilla's shallows of Madagascar
located on the cusp of a bustling trade
route it is the perfect place for an
ambush
here is our gang of pirates the Raiders
going head to head with a gang of rival
players the cutthroats victory goes to
the team with the most loot at the end
of the hunt
knowing how to sail with the wind is a
pirate's most precious skill use the
winds to increase your speed or to
position yourself for tactical advantage
in battle to reap the most rewards it is
best to split up some going inland
others keeping to the open sea
each warship has unique strengths the
frigates hull is reinforced its arsenal
equipped with numerous culverin cannons
the Brigantine is devastating up close
with a battering ram designed to break
any resistance the sloop-of-war kills
from afar with its crippling long-ranged
mortars and precise long nine cannons
open fire nothing will save you now
wowyou soggy not bad don't let bloodlust
cloud your purpose you're here for the
loop and so are your rivals score the
goods then back to your station the team
that escapes with the most loot claims
victory
searching for more targets on the
horizon our sloop-of-war spots a rival
pirate ship further inland
heavily reinforced hull our frigate
swoops in to save the day
bearing the brunt of the damage
[Music]
another day another victim
mr. Massey vamos coño our gang of
pirates is now taking aim at the frigate
and it will take team coordination to
take her down
[Music]
killing we can take a step with the
enemy ships broadside now vulnerable our
frigate rushes into border
based on blackened silver Betsy Lucas of
business
pirate hunters have been sent in
signaling the end of the hunt they
target the Pirates with the most stolen
loot time to mr. captain or we are good
balloons
the pirate hunter defenses are so strong
that the only option is escaping
the Brigantine is sacrificing herself to
buy time for the frigate who carries the
most loot
the frigate now needs to make its escape
through the reefs successful pilots know
when to run with their holes full and
the wind at their backs
[Applause]
thank you all very much I'd like to
invite you to play the lute hunt at the
Ubisoft booth at e3 and please register
for our live phases online oh and one
thing I forgot to mention the world of
skull and bones is one that evolves when
you act it reacts did not kiss the girls
my lips are moldy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm on right song that's right
[Music]
[Music]
the most pretty I'll live forever sing
like with me but not the one of those
with somebody I just wanna dance with
somebody I just wanna dance with
somebody
why
it's one of those
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
hey everyone I'm bebe Rexha and just
dance 2018 is out this October on all
consoles bye
[Applause]
you use it as a telephone you use it as
a camera
it's your music player your flashlight
calculator and GPS navigation device but
now finally the most high tech company
in the world has unlocked the mobile
phones true potential so that it can do
what it was truly meant to do you're
playing cowboys and Indians
[Music]
hey you kid we need you to come play
with us put on some cowboy [ __ ] meet us
outside and bring your phone
we're playing cowboys and Indians
[ __ ] Inuits are technically Native
American this new kid with MS Schade
[Music]
Fifty's guys a new [ __ ] new king
phone destroy yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
atlas jewel of the Pleiades
nova took us to the stars each new world
more incredible than the last
we had no idea what was waiting for us
the legion
which consumes everything in its path
they've never used StarLink before go
show them what it can do let's do this
come on I got it chase how's it going
breaking atmosphere
let's even the odds
judge we need to buy time for me to jump
start the engine
they are resisting ice barrage linking
fire motor
[Music]
we're up against impossible odds but
together
we'll adapt
[Applause]
hi I'm Matt Rose producer at Ubisoft
Toronto like many of you I grew up in
the 80s obsessed with sci-fi animation
comics and of course all the really cool
toys at Ubisoft Toronto we built a team
with a dream of bringing those amazing
childhood memories back to life for a
new generation
Starlin battle for Atlas allows you to
take control of a team of star pilots in
a massive open living star system
fighting to save Atlas from The
Forgotten Legion build your custom
starship and then adapt to new
challenges on the fly Linc extra armor
and heavy weapons to take on a huge
Legion prime search for aim since
ancient secrets lost on the worlds of
Atlas or outrun outlaws for an asteroid
field freedom is at the core of StarLink
battle for Atlas collect your way with
both physical starship collectibles and
digital versions available and even take
your game on the go using the power of
Nintendo switch visit Starling game comm
for more information and stay tuned for
many more surprises over the coming
months thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Rebecca kutas I'm the studio
director at Ubisoft and C it's a
pleasure for me to be back on stage
after our announcement at e3 last year
and we have had a since then a full year
of support and continuous development of
steep since the very beginning of this
project we have been working with
athletes and we have always been
impressed by their passion and
dedication we learned how one champions
but 300 days a year on a trampoline to
practice for that perfect landing we
learned how others make more than 6
million turns to practice with a 15 they
have to raising competition these
athletes they travel through the world
to train with the best to compete with
the strongest and to challenge
themselves with the most experienced and
skilled coaches it's truly a level of
passion and dedication that goes well
beyond our everyday lives and when you
talk to the very best of these men and
women you realize that there is
something they always have in back of
the minds at all times it's a dream that
takes years of preparation for just one
go at that unforgettable moment this
December with our first steep expansion
this is the journey you will take enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
as a child you would wait and watch the
faraway
you always knew that you beat from the
work while they
[Applause]
the cube would change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was lost but now
I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi my name is Dan hey and I'm the
executive producer of Far Cry the brand
as well as the creative director of Far
Cry 5 I'd like to introduce you to hope
County Montana vast beautiful rugged a
place where people don't even lock their
front door anymore but that's how it
used to be today Hope County's been
overrun by a fanatical cult you find
yourself trapped deep in cult territory
cut off from the rest of the world they
closed the roads there's no cell phone
signal no 9-1-1 people are [ __ ] scared
I had to say
and just up ahead the small town of
Falls End has been completely overrun if
you're going to survive you and your
guns for hire are gonna need to save it
but to do that well you're gonna need to
raise some hell
we got pegas Sam looks like a war zone
one
water tower guy
I'm in position
we're all they dad will you walk in the
light of our Father let burn boom
[ __ ]
boom boom boom boom bang back for need
mohel of the way world and I love the
way to roll that
[Music]
boom-boom-boom turn it up [ __ ] quiet
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
where's your master I don't deal with
domesticated I eat the [ __ ] ain't got no
master but I do have your little to me
show me the idol
show me the Redeemer you go mate
yo don't hand it over
I got a hot date don't do late monkeys
got a date what what what what what what
the Swiss [ __ ] chocolate pink bon
appetito I want every [ __ ] cop in
this [ __ ] city after that grab my
chassis knock see
[Music]
damn
do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's about bloody time hmm let's see
what we got
moksha
just as yama described it true freedom
lies beyond
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
first of all I want to say a big thank
you to all the teams who worked very
very very hard on creating all all the
ESL this world again thank you to all
these these teams behind us I want also
to say thank you to Eve with all my
heart
thank you for making this happen this is
this is just amazing and also a special
thanks to the fans of being good and
evil for sticking with us for so long
about party time 15 years almost so
welcome to system 3 our story takes
place before the birth of jade in a
multi-ethnic multicultural human society
in a distant solar system it is a time
when corporations create hybrids in
their labs and enslave them to colonize
the stars in order to compete for power
and cosmic resources with our crew of
crazy and unforgettable characters we
fight in the name of freedom and the
right to determine our own fate among
the stars and we will helm massive star
ferrying vessels through territories as
spectacular as they are dangerous
we've been working very hard just on the
technology during 3 years and today we
have a seamless online playground where
we can travel across space at the speed
of light we can explore mysterious
cities and discover and none lands by
ourselves or with friends and we want
you to participate in the making of this
great adventure join our space monkey
program
today and help us make beyond good and
evil a world that will challenge us and
bring us together four thousand
adventure thrills and fan and these Eve
just join us Jesus thank you thank you
okay congratulation you guys you know
Gabrielle and Michelle you've done a
fantastic job
it's amazing what I've been you've been
able to achieve and you and I and all
the teams and the power of creating
games that will amaze all the gamers and
I think video games can help us to grow
and to get better so thank you very much
thank you congratulations
so now I would like to thank everyone
here in the room and those who are
watching us from home thank you for
listening today and thank you for
playing our games so to all the teams at
Ubisoft thank you for your incredible
imagination and enthusiasm all of us
here we wish you all a lot of fun
playing games this year so thank you
very much and have a great
[Applause]
okay wait look most importantly it's not
over the show is not over fault hey
everyone welcome back to games lost III
stage we just wrapped up ubisoft press
conference and we're here to talk about
what we saw I think we all want to get
to beyond get an evil - but we are going
to save it for later I want to talk more
about it I want to go back through what
we did see although Beyond Good and Evil
2 is probably the biggest surprise like
earlier in the year we were talking
about how Michelle and cell had
mentioned that they probably wouldn't be
showing anything this year yeah here we
are and still getting over the shock of
it but uh another big surprise uh Kelly
I'm gonna ask you about Mario Rabbids
Kingdom battle because seem pretty
pissed about it beforehand well I mean I
wasn't actually angry I I feel bad
because when I saw that guy crying I was
like oh no I'm a jerk so no it looks it
looks really good I would I wish that um
Rabbids weren't the minions of a few B's
I'll give you soft world because um I
really I still don't like their
aesthetic but this game I mean like the
gameplay looks really good I'm actually
excited to play this yeah I'm a huge
XCOM fan and I never thought that you
could combine Rabbids and Mario and I
feel weird saying I really want to play
this yeah I look forward to playing this
on a switch - I feel like it's like
custom-made to be on like a portable
thing I don't know what you do think
yeah I'm like strangely excited for it
and it's got that XCOM style but it's
gonna be much more accessible to social
it yeah more a younger audience a wider
audience mm-hmm I'm looking forward to
seeing if they do something with
multiplayer like if you've got a switch
with your buddy you just battle out with
like these XCOM style mechanics that
that'd be sick yeah yeah I was
pleasantly surprised even the little
mechanics they have in that game with
the idea like you can like set up
somebody and then they can launch you
across the map is that was a lot more
involved than I thought this game was
ever gonna be yeah it was this whole
conference is actually kind of
surprising yeah we expected a few things
obviously like Assassin's Creed origins
we knew was a thing Far Cry 5 same thing
the crew - they had announced back when
they announced Far Cry 5 and Assassin's
Creed origins when that had leaked but
we did see a little more accesory
origins but we actually saw more of it
at Microsoft they showed us like
that kind of cinematic trailer yeah well
um I don't know didn't really do much
for you guys after we see a play already
let's like I said they're gonna show off
gameplay later on but yeah that's kind
of what we all wanted right we just got
to see it being played out in the Sun
yeah they're just trying to show off
more of the world I guess
Egypt and what's Alexandria and where
else are we gonna be it's um
I know it's like 49 BCE um that's a good
question there's like uh areas I'm not
familiar with like terms are not
familiar with they might be just like
made up for the game but like I said you
see like Horus statues and Anubis
statues and like we can see the animals
in action yeah so the trailer just show
a little bit more about the environment
um which is sort of what I asked for but
also not what I asked for because I do
you want to know more about byuk the
main character yeah he was like the
touching on the like the slavery element
of ancient Egypt quite a bit as well
yeah I was um I'm intrigued by that I'm
curious how that battle factored in um
yeah it's interesting it's it's kind of
on the precipice of Egypt's demise is
the time period this is set in yeah um
so if that becomes a big part of the
story I'd be really really interested in
that yeah that's definitely an important
sort of issue when it comes to the
formation of the assassins order right
yeah yeah yeah like this sort of
liberation that they sort of encompass
within there's philosophy yeah most of
the games are set during huge time to
change thread Renaissance American
Revolution I guess the pirate game not
so much but peaking of that yeah we'll
get into Skull and Bones a little bit
but uh yeah so they showed a little more
sanskrit origins we we will have more
gameplay up for that game throughout the
week on GameSpot she could see more
there but because they didn't show too
much where anything about that I want to
move on from it the crew to notable
because it's not just cars anymore yeah
I feel like airplanes and boats and dirt
bikes like swooping over San Francisco
and then it flipped up down like upside
down the desert and the inception
universe yeah yes my question is if you
didn't master cars in the first game why
would you add just more vehicles oh that
is one way of looking at it I'm kind of
I'm Emily they go down the route that I
do it for has recently where they've
control a control scheme for the super
simulator and a control scheme for like
kind of anyone who just wants to play
casually mm-hmm but then adding in land
see and there and what looks like an
open world mud city everything is like
if you can race anything with an engine
on it from yeah that like I said in the
pre-show they need to do something
different they need to do something
unique to the crew and they have they've
done that I can't remember the last time
yeah they combined all these things a
racing game of these yeah the five hours
the first game I played one problem I
had was it felt very empty so maybe the
fact that you can do more than just
drive and stick to roads and now you can
off-road you can fly you can go through
like the bay like I don't know the show
San Francisco Bay yeah into that yeah
maybe more is better here in this case I
don't know Matt were you impressed by
the crew too at all or you mean Tapan
yeah I mean I definitely dig the legs
for multiple kind of vehicle types you
can use and it's just like just this
idea that you can just like drive and
all these different kinds of trances
mm-hm you know I'm kind of casually the
car game so this is Pike my interest
yeah yeah yeah cool so uh yeah they
showed off more that I'm interested to
see how those are all going to
interweave if it's like the crew the
cool thing was I was like you know open
world America I'm curious how you'll
transition between those different
vehicles because I don't know that they
really detail that it looked like it was
following the career of one like yeah so
it might be something like like you're
jack of all trades Motorsports guy
you're going through different like
tournaments yeah I can't imagine well I
could be wrong but it would be very cool
if you had like a decathlon style race
where you start in a car drive down yeah
to the beach getting a boat drive up to
where a seaplane is and take off that'd
be sick yeah that would if they could
find a seamless way to combine those
that'd be really good great racing game
I'd be into that we also saw like we
said we were wondering if we see
gameplay for South Park the fractured
but whole or we would see I just
cinematic they should have pretty
explicit cinematic as we kind of our
trailer I guess as we lead up to October
17th released 8 yes um October side know
is packed this year October November
like like maybe it's because the spring
was so loaded this year that I'm looking
ahead to the Fallen like it actually
gonna be kind of a relaxed fall but then
after
all these announcement specially after
Bethesda's they're like all our games
are coming out this fall or even this
summer October November insane and they
always are but even more so it seems
like this year but yeah they showed more
of a you know the [ __ ] character and how
you can you know create your own super
hero and how you're gonna be kind of
uniting South Park after the schism
between the two sides and you know
Avengers Civil War I like her name's
call girl I love it yeah uh uh I love
Wendy um yeah there's like a toolshed
he's not there oh yeah he was right
there
but yeah I'm looking forward to playing
this a lot actually they didn't show
much of the combat this time they showed
like brief glimpses of it but I think
we've done like in-depth kind of things
to that yeah or I don't know Callie just
just get you more excited or you kind of
just I'm still waiting for it I mean
this is definitely a South Park style
trailer so I am excited I like that they
are keeping the tongue-in-cheek like
yeah your franchise is going dry or
whatever he says uh and I like that you
get like all of the the favorites like
you know and of course Timmy is one of
my favorite characters and I like I I
don't know I'm just um I'm still wait I
don't think the trailer really relied
too much on existing South Park jokes so
um like I said before I think that if
they stick to like the kind of humor
without doing too many references a
feeling really strong yeah this made me
hopeful for that definitely yeah
hopefully it's a good South Park
experience in its own right not just
when it's mining the series yes
absolutely cool uh something really
weird that we saw not Mario Rabbids I'm
not backtracking thought that way it's
Elijah Wood came up on the screen during
a song conference yeah yeah transference
it's a VR experience apparently and from
what he says it's like it's based on
like allowing people to read that you're
revisiting other people's trauma past
trauma or like conscious so unguents
that makes me both very intrigued and
very nervous because if it's like a PTSD
thing um I mean VR has been used for
like psychiatric purposes to help people
with their phobias and with trauma and
so I think it's an interesting concept
but also do I want to go into somebody's
trauma yeah so um and also is a deeply
personal thing
this is a fictional character but I part
of that is like oh I don't know if I
personally can handle this I think maybe
that would hit me in the wrong way um of
course it's this whole trailer was just
super weird there's like a video in it
that's dated 2003 yeah there's there's
like records like medical records or
something I'm actually curious I like
the tone of the trailer
especially when the dude comes up he
says you'll be safe and then he's like
repeats it over less surely you'll
definitely be safe I've kind of got some
horror vibes from it yeah maybe they'll
go into that more oh yes creepy yeah um
I kind of like it what'd you think
Matt what are you excited for this at
all uh I mean VR is always tough
territory for me because I except for
some motion sickness oh I'm kind of cure
it it seems interesting but I don't know
I don't really know what to make of it
honest yeah I mean that we haven't we
don't know really what it is too much of
this is just I guess it's doing its job
and asking against ask questions I don't
know Dave is it something you could see
yourself absolutely not here the trailer
scared me I'm not playing alright I
guess I'm the only one
uh yeah well see how it's got this dude
I like this yeah this is the 2003 video
were talking about ah okay cool
so Skull and Bones apparently the video
actually kind of leaked right before
they did the announcement up enabled off
straight away but that was like during
the true - yeah now it's made but um
they're saying it was one of the
Ubisoft's like most celebrated worlds
and we were wondering what it was but
apparently they took Assassin's Creed 4
Black Flag the Caribbean and are making
just a game based in the bat world uh
but the more I watched the trailer and
the more the narrate the narrator was
telling us what was happening it sounds
almost like for honor with these classes
of pirate ships and how they like
there's actually actually a lot of
layers underneath kind of like with
these classes the frigate the the one
that's like more of a battering ram and
how it's not about killing other pirates
about getting away with loot I was kind
of hoping they said you could play it by
herself but I was kind of hoping just
for like a like a pirate like a
single-player triple a pirate story game
like I had in the fourth game I are
sorry the sass is greed for yeah but
it's kind of funny
strikes me it's funny that you come out
with Assassin's Creed 3 which I did not
like but I liked the naval combat and
then they made that into a game and then
I played that I was like I wish you
could just get rid of the Assassin's
Creed from this yeah oh yeah now they
made
that but you're not supposedly like a
multiplayer experience and I'm curious
again it's the sea of thieves thing I'm
wondering how this will frack like
fracture into a wider world and for the
record people saying is competing with
sea of thieves see if thieves releasing
soon like like a few hours ago
exploration yeah this is coming out in
2018 really 2000 parrots are not
everybody saying like Oh pirates are hot
now like they're all coming back at two
games what is like we get things like
stop don't get lot of trends if there's
no trend like uh I'm sorry
ranting kelly ha well then wanted say
something in the middle of my swimming
freely sorry sorry I just uh on the the
sea of thieves comparison yeah I think
Dave has a point that see if these is
much more exploration focused this seems
to be a little more we saw a lot of
combat in this in this look at at
gameplay so I don't think they're
necessarily comparable and I don't think
I mean just because they're both pirate
games doesn't mean they're necessarily
competing I think they'd probably will
be attracting different audiences sure
um so I don't know I kinda just wanted
to watch parts of the Caribbean after
seeing this I was like oh yeah I worst
one yeah no no I meant the first one um
and also I really liked the the cool
lady pirate in the yeah I was like oh
yeah she's so badass
she the one ended up sacrificing herself
for no or she get away at the end I
can't remember I don't know I was busy
treating about Lady Pirates I'm really I
want to play this yeah but I do I hope
it's not just I'm all like a MOBA ish
kind of game with the different class of
ships I know that's being reductive it's
not at all but I wanted to actually be
more about just feeling because it
looked this looks really similar to I
think there's a lot to think about from
from what we've seen like yeah like when
when firaon it was first showed off
there was no hint of single-player so a
player story isn't out of the realms of
possibilities
right um the whole season thing is quite
interesting in how the world's gonna
evolve the one thing the one minor thing
at this point because I'm so hype this
game I adore pirates I mean pirate at
using to you like I love the pirate
stuff one thing you know they did awful
things Dave a joking I like that ass
they're loud yeah the one minor gripe I
did it when they
aw dude I really wanted that to turn
from from your captain get a sword out
jump across to the ship and it turned
into like a like a small fighting minion
right it was actually had to fight the
other captain and use your crew to kill
the enemy crew that would have ya crazy
that would be credible especially like
if they could use some of the engine
from for honor or something like goodbye
bethi's there I wonder if maybe just for
this presentation they kind of faded to
black and then came back and said loot
stolen I hope so because the whole
boarding system just having a pop up is
a little climactic like like I could
like a quick time like oh that chips
down go up yes exes we got a rope with
you cut this out and a blunderbuss yeah
like a missed opportunity if the team
doesn't really cool I mean I'm excited
for this um
surprised by it but yeah yeah definitely
surprised yeah it's weird it's ever been
a lot of people said a Sanskrit for was
great but I didn't really love the
Assassin's Creed aspects alright and now
like what looks like a decent this has
two screens coming out that's kind of
being mean it looks good I'm not you
know and then now we have this pirate
game coming out it looks like they split
it off where they needed to and it's
exciting the best parts of both and run
with it and let them be their own things
let them paint and they remove that
expectation from Assassin's Creed yeah
because you know constantly people like
what can we get to the kind of black
flag ass game like Walter yeah look here
it's just a part game I still get like
there's a-- go back and play black flag
just be in that world and i love like
hearing the the songs just yeah yeah the
shanties Ave yeah and the show the
economists soggy nutmeg or something
yeah something like that
I heard salty nutmeg so I'm gonna use
both of those yeah um just dance I don't
know if we have much to say I'm sure
it's gonna be more people gets on why
gets on epuap uh Matt and I are a couple
of nerds about this kind of thing so of
course we were like then I got the kpop
okay well oh yeah yeah you know what you
think of the dance the one thing I
didn't want to see I'm just kidding it
was well choreographed I respect their
talent oh no another weird thing that
came out was StarLink battle for Atlas
like yeah what a weird conference the
more I thought yeah darling valve for
Atlas it's like a toys to life game
after companies are closing because they
made toys to life games yeah uh what is
up with this that you get made like if I
I'm this I don't mean this in a bad way
this is a compliment if I saw this when
I was twelve I would
everything I ever got at this game I
guess I would throw up I would throw up
- yeah excitement yeah it's a toys life
game where you're just building the
spaceship and you're taking off like the
missile pods and putting new Gatling
guns on in mid-battle yeah it's like
what you would do with your Legos in
your head except you get it in a video
game yeah it's like I would have been so
excited about this I would play it with
my little brother like and I just I
loved the how Ernest the presentation
was yeah I think there were a lot of
really earnest developers in this
conference - Mikey Eve himself yeah
and so just watching this I was like
well this is just one of those like
childhood dreams that turn into
somebody's job like I really got that
impression from a show so have then
there's like an actual character they
just put on it looked like so I guess
we'll see more of this coming I don't
know if we make we have a demo set up
for this week I'm hoping cuz I would
like to see this but is that nostalgia
enough to carry a genre a genre but I
mean toys to life has been faltering a
lot how do you there's an infinity they
kind of I think it's really gonna depend
on the price point of yeah the actual
toys like they can't like especially
because you're gonna be able to change
them so much I I really think they're
gonna have to be fairly like fairly
cheap yeah right they also said that you
could buy them digitally as well and I
don't I'm saying take my said that and
I'm like kind of talking about broad
range of games that's a different age
group they're going for then like Skull
and Bones right and it's like South Park
yeah I hope I guess but uh but I do they
down steeps first expansions like Winter
Olympics we don't have to linger around
this too long of the games we thought
they would get DLC sorry aside from for
honor and like Rainbow six siege I guess
steep was the one game we talked a
little bit about but as the ones getting
DLC this December I was surprised
actually I did I think that actually
happened um but then Far Cry 5 we saw
more initially the one trailer we saw
Kelly he said his behind closed doors
with like a month or two ago yeah I had
seen that before
um and I I do like the haunting tone of
it but then the presentation it was
there was such a dissonance between the
trailer which has this really like
somber haunting it's it's melancholic in
ways yeah ominous thank you
um but then the presentation is like
boom boom [ __ ] and I'm like yeah
okay I don't know this is my main
concern with this game is how do you
marry a game that's fun to play and
exciting and bombastic with like trying
to hit this like cuz they're they're
really leaning into this yeah super hard
like if they were kind of like making it
light or being more self-aware about oh
yeah it's kind of ridiculous should
going in and blowing up this cult or
whatever um I think that would be one
thing this is okay this is very serious
this guy is clearly in control of these
people is very manipulative and there's
like all this seven deadly sins imagery
and you know the trailers and then the
the gameplay is just like alright
blowing stuff up yes don't know how you
happily marry those things also the
creative director was really somber when
he came out he's like rugged Montana
wilderness and he's like [ __ ] and
then laughs I had to say like come on
buddy you don't I don't know and then it
seems like he had the same problem but
yeah anybody you look at Wolfenstein -
they're just going all album bombastic
and really excited that's a great
comparison actually like that's that's
the way to really hit it the right way
how do you do that tone right car cries
always struggle with this to some extent
I mean at least the one that comes to my
mind is with Far Cry 3 where you know
they it's very like you know bombastic
gamers you shooting stuff like but but
then they also criticizes you for being
that having those inclinations right but
it's never been able to sort of settle
those things it's almost contradictory I
mean it seems to be just showing up here
again with these two different drastic
tones
yeah obviously we don't know how I mean
that was just like kind of a gameplay
trailers right no I do want to talk
about the dog really fast yeah if we
made riot I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do a
cool hard right with my criticism and
should be like that dog rules thank you
a gun he's a good boy I love him he's
perfect if my dog Lilly is watching at
home I love you um yeah I'm looking
forward to seeing how those allies play
out like how you actually because I have
the one was like her name was grace and
then Nick I might be Nick right is like
the he has the biplane everything and
yes grace is a sniper and then boomer is
a good boy he's a good dog oh yes um and
then the one that surprised everyone
Beyond Good and Evil 2 because I mean
like I think a lot of people would have
expected it if it were for the fact that
Michelle and sell kind of strongly
hinted that he wouldn't yeah be here
yeah I don't know what you guys think of
it
after seeing it it's a prequel yeah I
said before Jade yeah yeah um again I
don't know Beyond Good and Evil the
first one to well but I don't know Matt
you played at Cal you seemed excited for
this I I'm intrigued
IDOT at that familiar with Beyond Good
and Evil I mean is this tonally at all
similar it it's it seems fair I mean not
to say that it's incredibly different
but it definitely is it's clear that
beot like this series is basically a has
is growing older I guess you know I mean
I don't like in terms of the tone right
it like the amount of swear words that I
heard yeah it seemed like chert rising
considering what there were a lot of
f-bombs yeah yeah more than South Park I
think there was more swearing than yeah
park trailers just saying something
yeah seem like they're trying kind of
hard for my tastes but uh but I like the
presentation the rest of this I don't
like get how the gameplay is gonna be
this is obviously you know not gameplay
but right you know like that seems like
you're it's got a pretty ragtag group of
characters that I might be into oh yeah
absolutely I guess in terms of like the
amount of detail in the world it it
really does feel and like like it's
completely different not like completely
different it's depart wait how do I
settle this it's just like seeing a game
that you know like those trying to
create this kind of world the places you
to in seeing that like world coming now
it's almost they almost seem so drastic
yeah but they're the same obviously but
oh yeah I know you mean have it in your
head one way you have a new memory one
way yeah and it's crazy seeing it like
this yeah yeah it was interesting
especially as someone who doesn't really
have the context of the first game but
people seemed excited about it and it
was definitely a surprise something we
didn't know about at all yeah um I don't
know any last thoughts Dave Ubisoft how
do you think the conference went overall
there was there are tons of surprises
there like were saying that we didn't be
expected to see Rainbow six and ferrán
oh yeah didn't get those but in in the
place of that we got like incredible new
IPs and things that like so many people
are excited about getting that like what
is the spectrum from the young to the
old things and I've not seen a
conference a long time that there's
literally been something for everyone
yeah and there was a lot new surprises
so I think Ubisoft killed it yeah yeah
Matt what about you yeah honestly think
they did a great job
mean that as they've said that it really
does sort of focus on sort of different
games for different kinds of audiences
and you know they've announced a couple
new like I piece like you know I'm big
fan Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag so
seeing like you know the new pirate game
with that sort of realm is was fantastic
and and then finally showing me more
Beyond Good and Evil 2 was it was just a
great way to wrap that whole thing up I
really yeah they really hit it at the
park yeah Kelly what's your final take
yeah I think of all the conferences
we've seen so far it was really really
strong like everyone else that I I think
that bringing something for everybody is
really smart I think Ubisoft
kind of has that breadth of like in
their library
you know from just dance to South Park
is if you're hitting a very different
audience and I just liked there was a
lot of earnestness in the conference
that I really liked every time a
developer started crying I started
crying a little bit um yeah yeah just
oh the thing I like about that is that
it shows that somebody put a lot of care
into what you're seeing and and you
remind you that it's you know even if
you aren't impressed by something like
somebody put a lot of work into it and
that's the kind of thing that it's nice
to remember especially during e3 when
we're very busy seeing a lot of
different things that everything you
know you can you can try to split your
attention between a lot of things that
deserve it and so there there were a lot
of things here that were worth paying
attention to you yeah I really liked it
yeah um so that will do it for Ubisoft
we do have Sony's press conference
coming up at 6 p.m. Pacific later today
and we're starting our post show or
sorry pre-show at 5:30 but you can tune
in and see gameplay throughout the show
if you want to come in a little earlier
I'll be back to talk about that and then
we'll have Nintendo tomorrow after they
do their Nintendo direct style kind of
thing but in the meantime if you want to
look after look out for more gameplay
from Ubisoft from Bethesda last night
from EA and Microsoft you can do so on
GameSpot stay tuned and we'll see you
later today